henri guaino un an après 1 an après son
élection comme député de la 3e
circonscription l'ancienne plume de
nicolas sarkozy que l'on entend beaucoup
dans les médias nationaux est venu à la
rencontre de ses électeurs et
sympathisants
un retour aux sources de la vie locale
pour évoquer sa première expérience
législatives j'ai appris d'abord parce
qu'on apprend on apprend toujours dans
des cantons fait de nouvelles
expériences lhc nouvelle expérience de
vie c'est une nouvelle vie quand j'ai
appris j'ai appris fonctionnement du
parlement états d'âme d'un groupe
parlementaire un détour également par la
vie départementale aux prochaines
municipales henri guaino soutiendra des
mers sa circonscription comme philippe
brillault qui vient de réintégrer l'ump
ou encore véronique côté millard mer des
clayes-sous-bois pourtant passé de l'ump
à lui ni elle a été là dans les moments
difficiles de cette campagne législative
et quand on regarde son bilan au que ce
bois
il n'y a pas de doute qu'elle mérite
d'être réélu donc gérer la soutenir
quant à philippe brillault là il est
désormais de nouveaux membres de la
famille ump henri guaino n'entend pas
jouer d'autres rôles au sein de l'ump
départementale il soit dit il restait
une voix forte au sein de l'hémicycle
parlementaire et poursuivre des combats
nationaux qui lui tiennent à coeur
contre le mariage pour tous par exemple
il reviendra s'il faut battre le pavé
pour dire non à l'adoption et à la
procréation médicalement assistée